International Master Danny wrench here
attempting to provide some instruction
on the game between magnus carlsen the
car and uncle more from the Brooklands
championship here we have a scotch
Chicago played the Bishop to c5
classical variation Magnus thought about
it for a second decided to go for his
line with Knight to b3 and after the
main line moves are played here Magnus
pauses as his last main game in this
line with Queen d2 was a win over back
row from the nine Gene masters in 2012
that game went like this and it's
important for this game because you'll
see a common idea for black which is to
put this knight on d4 because one the
bishop on this diagonal will help with
defense and create counter play white
doesn't like that so Magnus played Queen
d3 in that game but eventually achieved
an edge and went on to win this move
Queen e2 has been played by most of the
strong players to play this line since
then which is guys like Caruana of all
the Ketan among others but here Magnus
plays this move Bishop to g5 now Bishop
to g5 creates an immediate pin
impossible threats at times with 95
though not right away
Carl played castles which isn't the most
common move in the database but makes
sense queen of three is a new idea
played by both David Nabarro and Hui ho
you fought recently white is a very
simple intention wants to take here in
double the pawns
you'll see the Takara just pause there
and looked up at the sky trying to
remember his lines just like a karo does
so well and guess what he did he
remembered his line with 94 exclaim of
iatch this similar idea that we saw in
the book program comes into play the
bishop comes to d4 where it defends both
f6 and creates tactics on c3 Magnus has
a good thing and then decides he has
nothing better but to castlelong
allow black to take on c3 by the way
Queen takes c3 would allows to Knight
takes e4 winning upon so bee takes c3 is
forced you think that white should still
have a little bit of an edge with the
bishop pair here as well as the
potential to attack on the King side now
we're seeing Magnus actually play these
moves here and will slow down for a
second to say that on rook e8 acted the
move that was played in the game we
start to see a forcing line that maybe
maybe means that we won't see Magnus
Carlsen play this line again as white
doesn't really achieve much heading from
the middlegame transition into the
endgame Hikaru is thinking right now
about what he wants to do so he takes on
c3 and then place this line rook e8 as
we just talked about
one thing I want to get to before
they're there is you're going to see in
a couple moments here after rook e8
Bishop c4 d6 White has a critical
decision to make
go to the endgame with Bishop takes f6
or to play for h3 or moves like rook to
e1 to guard the e pawn any idea that
keeps the pieces on the board the middle
game might give white a little bit
better chances if he's intending on
creating an attack against the black
King leaving the pin here but Magna
sense of thinking about the position and
decides there really is nothing better
here than to take on f6
I've analyzed this h3 line a little bit
and what I can say is that it's probably
just about equal neither side really
achieving too much I think that black
can still play moves like Bishop e6 and
try to simplify the position and White's
King may end up being just as weak as as
blacks so back to the game what we're
seeing now is that Bishop takes f6 was
played moves that are all force coming
to play and in watching this video live
actually without knowing the result of
the game my first thought is White must
have a little bit of an edge here but a
caramel quickly plays f5 the move you
just saw which the whole point is to
undone and leaving black with no
positional weakness will point out the
fact that really black is probably the
only one who can win this game taking
advantage of white's weaknesses on the
Queen side long-term is not going to be
an easy task but f5 is a really strong
move by Hikaru and you'll see that
Magnus goes into as long as think of the
game Hikaru looks around that confident
head looked to the side
Magnus decides the best thing he can do
as Bishop d5 a good move that not only
defends the e4 pawn but also puts
pressure on b7 making it a little bit
tricky to develop the only issue is that
Picaro is going to be able to simplify
getting rid of his weaknesses by taking
here place c6 to remove the Bishop from
b7 and if black can coordinate the
pieces meaning complete his development
he'll have eliminated White's only
remaining advantage which is these two
Brooks and one of the things to realize
is that if you eliminate this temporary
advantage of a development lead white is
actually the one with the long-term
issues again we see a carl play brook e5
very confidently and more and more it
seems that the position is headed toward
a game where white really doesn't have
very good winning chances with the
weaknesses
on the on the kingside here some very
good moves are played here Bishop to d5
offers the trade of rooks which even
though it seems that trading would be a
good idea it's Magnus's last chance to
try to take advantage of the lack of
development and that is you remove
blacks only develop peace with hopes of
infiltrating the once a karo plays King
f8 Magnus really has nothing Rickey
Forza is a sort of phantom threat Bishop
f5 is coming to relocate over to the the
King side and once it Carla achieves
this Bishop on g6 as we'll see in just a
moment there really is nothing much here
for white to show it's all black from
here on out h4 is played not a bad move
I guess if white gets the majority with
g4 and h5 will still see f7 be a
weakness that was hardly a threat after
h5 by Hikaru what we're going to see
black tried to do is activate the rook
put this pawn on d5 at some point to
block the bishop on v3 and if that if
that occurs then this bishop will be out
of play which is why after rook d8 what
you just saw after rook to d8 Magnus
played Bishop c4 to d3 much rather have
this bishop traded than have it stuck
over on b3 where black might essentially
be up a piece after King g7 though we
see the white really doesn't have a lot
of good options trading into the brook
ending is still going to leave him with
the positional weaknesses to go with so
Magnus tries to create some threats if
establishing the pawn on e5 happens the
brook to b4 might come so Vacarro stops
that would be 6 and after g3 we're
seeing Hikaru plays c5 which immediately
threatens counter play Magnus is a
little worried about it placed Bishop to
e2 really he just doesn't want the
bishop in a place where it can be
attacked with tempo and maybe has this
idea of targeting the h5 pawn though
these moves here are sort of natural for
white to try to create counter play what
we're going to see is that they headed
to a position where Magnus had a
critical decision to make in this
position with the pawn on e5 he's still
thinking about it
after rook f6 but the critical decision
to make has to do with do I allow Hikaru
the chance to take on it for naught I'm
going to give you a clue that the wrong
decision was made by Magnus
unfortunately followed by a wrong
decision if you're her car or Nakamura
here Magnus doesn't see the right
a right way to guard the f2 pawn so he
sort of has to play this move Bishop of
three instead of moving the rook
the only problem is that accurate
calculation here by Hikaru might have
might have led him to a line that goes
like rook takes f4 pawn takes up foreign
King f6x clam giving up the d5 pawn
after Bishop takes d5 King f5 not only
is this pawn threatened but the most
important threat is the infiltration of
the King to the Kings side a line like
this might have occurred white doesn't
have to play a five but this pawn is
going to fall black will remove the King
and an outside pass pawn is a huge
advantage this is all my own analysis
but in the end I realized that black
will begin an endgame up a pawn and
likely the only one who can win but
we'll find out is that probably that was
a car was only real chance to win after
playing a great game with black
equalizing and eventually out playing as
they transitioned into the endgame but
Accardo chose not to take on at four
instead played rook to d6 and we headed
toward the line that you're seeing now
both sides moving back and forth here we
just saw this move rook a four by Magnus
but neither side has anything sort of an
attempt to draw four by Hikaru to repeat
Magnus says okay we'll see if you really
want to draw the car was thinking hmm
I'd really like to beat Magnus right now
I'm going to go for the win with d5 and
after Bishop f1 Brooke to b6 it seems
that he may have made the right decision
though Magnus plays a little tickle
again and says how you going to guard
this point you still want to draw magna
Carlos says no I'll play Brooke a6 if
you play Bishop takes d5 I have ideas
like rook to a2 and Bishop b4 is met by
rook a for a very interesting idea I
think that here Magnus defends the C to
pawn the bishops get traded on d3 I
wasn't sure who I liked in the work
ending at first I don't think either one
of them were at first I thought that
Hikaru must have an edge still with the
positional weaknesses but will find that
he's unable to deal with the H pawn
without just getting behind it and
that's what happens here
after g4 is played they take the check
the King activates itself both sides are
getting under real-time pressure now
under 30 seconds I believe although we
can't exactly see the clock Magnus is
really living off the increment with a
three minutes +2 second time control
this move rooks u1 is really nice
because not only does it prevent the
rook from coming behind but it threatens
to advance this is the move the really
secure drawing chances for white you're
Carl's frustrated as you can see he
doesn't quite know what to do
moves the
which threatens b4 and d4 but Magnus's
no thank you he says all right I'll play
b4 anyways reading to bring my rook over
behind the poem which of course is a
great idea but after rook to g3 he
realizes I can't trade into the King
upon ending because white will win with
this outside pass pawn I have to try to
come behind but Magnus's no thank you
all right well then I got to give my
king behind the pawn that's fine but in
the end will I be able to pick up these
pawns before you can get this turns out
now pick our winds up having just enough
counter play with the thread on the f2
pawn both sides lose these pawns and in
the end Magnus decides there's no way to
effectively remove the rook from being
behind the pawn which is why we end up
in a draw and ending here probably I
moved a little bit too fast there but if
you want to see it even faster you can
click here in case you're not interested
in the commentary or the long version
here the moves get repeated a draw is
agreed neither sides happy about it and
unfortunately one of the most
anticipated matchups of the tournament
most exciting ended in a peaceful result
we always love to see blood but in the
end very good game for both of these
players fun for me to analyze as it was
a scotch and hopefully you learned
something thanks for watching